hola de nuevo okay mira bueno cuando la
reserva federal hace operaciones de
mercado abierto aquí lo escribo
operaciones de mercado abierto lo que
hace es lo que hace aquí es literalmente
imprimen dinero la reserva federal
imprime dinero aquí dibujo unos cuantos
dólares
que no necesariamente debe ser dinero en
efectivo puede ser también dinero
electrónico y lo usa para comprar
valores de tesorería a corto plazo en
los mercados abiertos por eso se le
llama operaciones de mercado abierto
entonces a cambio tiene valores de
tesorería y bueno todo el propósito de
esto se incrementa la demanda en
tesorería y por lo tanto incrementa el
precio en las tesorerías bajando así la
tasa de interés pero el principal
objetivo aquí es que tome ese dinero y
lo pone en el sistema bancario porque
bueno tal vez compran tesorería a
personas oa bancos también quizás a
instituciones y ellos toman ese dinero
que obtuvieron de las tesorerías lo
depositan después en bancos así que tal
vez aquí éste va al banco uno y tal vez
este de acá va al banco 2
tenemos más dinero en los bancos en el
banco 1 y en el banco dos tienes que la
oferta de dinero sube y también la
demanda la demanda de reservas subirá
entonces aquí tenemos este dinero estás
aquí son reservas tenemos a la demanda
por reservas se está incrementando y
quizás antes el dinero antes de que
entrara en el sistema
el banco 2 tenía escasez de reservas
pero ya no porque la gente depositó en
el entonces tenemos la oferta de dinero
subiendo tenemos la demanda de dinero
bajando y en particular yo aquí hablo de
reservas y entonces la tasa de préstamos
a corto plazo bueno va a bajar el precio
del dinero bajará y eso es la tasa de
fondos de la reserva federal lo voy a
poner aquí la tasa de fondos de reserva
federal y bueno veamos es la tasa
objetivo la tasa objetivo que la reserva
federal fija para la tasa de préstamos
de reservas a corto plazo entre estos
bancos entre los bancos eso es la tasa
de fondos de la reserva federal y ésta
va a bajar y así es como la reserva
federal intenta dar un un porcentaje
fijo
ahora viajemos a la situación de hoy en
día donde la tasa de fondos de las
reservas ya está en ceros pero la
reserva federal quiere seguir metiendo
dinero en la economía y lo quiere hacer
de una manera más directa entonces lo
que hace es ahora aún imprime dinero
pero está está usando ese dinero para
comprar otras cosas puede comprar deudas
a largo plazo o tesorería de mayor
duración me refiero a cosas como del
estilo 10 años bonos de tesorería a 10
años o quizás quizás más a más plazo
también podrían comprar otros activos
activos distintos podrían por ejemplo
comprar valores respaldados por
hipotecas y aquí el objetivo no
solamente es incrementar la oferta de
dinero el objetivo de flexibilidad
cuantitativa es suavizar la situación
que ocurre en ciertas partes del mercado
si se ve que hay un congestionamiento en
el mercado de valores de respaldos de
hipotecas eso es lo que los mueve a
participar ahí por lo tanto esto de aquí
es flexibilización cuantitativa